all right one other thing this is from
the daily wire flying car prototypes are
starting to take off science fiction is
one step closer to reality as several
companies debut working prototypes for
flying cars the American startup ASCA
showed off its A5 model at the 2023
Consumer Electronics Show the A5 is an
electric vertical takeoff and Landing
vehicle roughly the size of a standard
SUV that is reportedly capable of
driving at 70 miles per hour on the road
and flying at speeds of up to 150 miles
per hour all I want to say about this is
that the flying car thing it's the kind
of thing that you think sounds really
great and cool before you're able to
drive yourself and then you get a
license and you get out on the roads and
you realize what a terrible idea this
would actually be because the vast
majority of people can't drive on the
ground let alone driving in the sky
can't be too careful a lot of bad
drivers out there it's amazing that most
Americans Drive every day for decades
and yet never figure out how to do it I
mean the roads are are infested with
people driving these big chunks of metal
70 miles per hour and they're just
sitting behind the wheel they have no
idea what they're doing